I don't have an opening joke for this
one because this this movie just can't
be summed up like that
[Music]
annihilation I don't know how much
people care about hearing my opinion on
this the movies been well in whatever
theaters yeah it was playing it has been
out for a little while now and didn't do
especially well so I'm guessing people
don't care but I saw it and I want to
talk about it
I'll go spoiler free for a while but
eventually I will get into spoilers I'll
give you the heads up when I get there
so there was no way I wasn't gonna see
this movie I wasn't sure it was gonna
get to see it in the theater but I did
and I'm glad that I did Alex Garland is
a person whose work I've been following
for quite a while I I really took notice
of his writing he wrote things like 28
days later and the beach Dredd he really
does interesting concepts often sci-fi
tinged and with his actual directorial
debut ex machina that was one of my
favorite films of that year so I was
definitely have my eye on this and it is
it is what I wanted it is heady it is
atmospheric it is a little bit mind
bendy
it is beautifully shot it is also not
for everybody I would think if you've
seen ex machina pretty much whatever you
thought about that you're probably gonna
think about this now that's not me going
like it's just the same it's not it's a
very different movie and I'm it's
possible that if you do like one that
doesn't mean you'll like the other boat
what I mean by that is you you would
watch this in a few scene ex machina you
would definitely go oh yeah same
director because it's got that same very
measured deliberate pacing it is not
going at an exceptionally rapid pace
it's on a bit of a slow boil although it
gives us sort of an initial hook much
earlier than ex
kena does but they're all kind of
similar trajectories as far as how
gradual the build-up is and that a lot
of it is just about kind of just
dwelling in the space where all this is
happening so premise wise so what we've
got is there is a phenomenon going on
down on down of the southern coast in
America it's been dubbed the shimmer
it's it's the sort of dome of energy for
lack of a better term that has been
slowly expanding out now people can pass
through it it's not like a force field
or something but every team that has
been sent inside to explore what's going
on in there has never come out until one
person does and there's a lot of
weirdness involved in that and so this
film follows Natalie Portman and four
other women as they go in as the latest
team to give this a shot and each member
has various reasons for being involved
in this particular mission so from there
they go in and then it's just about what
they see what they experience what they
find out and that's really all that I
can say that that doesn't involve
spoilers other than you know just to say
it is it's a film that offers I think
enough explanations for what's going on
that you should be able to follow it
it's not gonna be like under the skin or
it just presents the stuff to you and
expects you to put all the pieces
together yourself it does give just
enough exposition just enough
explanation but barely and a lot of what
you see is not gonna be explained as
it's happening like you'll get a few
lines yeah basically middle and second
third of the movie ish that are
explaining to you some of the core
concepts of what is going on but then
later you're going to see
things that are very much are
extrapolations of things that you were
told but these things aren't gonna be
explained explicitly they do make sense
with what you know but you gotta be
paying attention so it's that kind of
movie and for me for me I really liked
it I enjoyed it quite a bit I think the
one thing I would say is I I thought the
acting was all good I suspect some
people are gonna call the acting stiff
because it's ultimately it's a it's a
contemplative atmosphere peace it's not
a character focused or character driven
piece we're not here to really get to
know these characters inside and out and
so if that's your normal hooking for a
movie if that's you know you you really
need the bottom of the characters this
might not get you there for my purposes
you know and what I like from this kind
of material I really did enjoy it so I
am gonna start getting into spoilers now
okay here we go so I love the stuff that
they see in the shimmer just the little
weirdness and initially just like plants
that seem to be you know all lumped
together and in similar shape but also
all different colors all a little a
little bit off things just seem a little
weird then that alligator attacks them
and it opens its mouth and inside its
mouth like that's that's not normal and
what this movie does better than any
movie that I can think of off the top my
head from the last few years it's just
atmosphere this environment in the
setting is beautiful and horrifying
simultaneously impressively so like the
the image I keep coming to is the the
body of that guy because because we see
the video of the the guy getting cut
open and his insides and moving around
and later we see his body in the strand
out pool and it looks like it has
exploded in
vibrant maybe fungus maybe plant life we
don't really know but like it from a
distance you see the the shape and the
color of it it it is kind of beautiful
but then you look closer and you go oh
that's his skull at the top and the jaws
over here and the rest of the skulls
over here and that's his tongue sticking
out and it looks like his head freakin
exploded and that's kind of horrifying
yet still at the same time oddly
beautiful I love that aesthetic I think
that's amazing and brilliant I like the
tail end of it I like the climax a lot I
like that it doesn't get an O it doesn't
get over-explained you're just presented
with what with what happens but like I
say I think we're given just enough
information prior to all this to be able
to follow what it is that's going on the
characters are fine the the one who kind
of goes nuts you know saw that coming
relatively early but you know it worked
in it wasn't like it wasn't like
sunshine where it just kind of felt like
boy that came out of nowhere like no I
kind of figured that was gonna happen
and thankfully she wasn't like the end
boss of the movie although it's funny I
used that term because I think it was
about 40 minutes into this movie I had
an odd thought and I haven't been able
to shake it sense I think this movie as
much as I like it
would have made a better video game now
if you've seen this movie this might
make more sense to you but you know the
the film was kind of you know like I
said deliberately paced and you know as
you get to wander through this very
beautiful yet unsettling environment
imagine instead of being led through the
hand narrative Leafers him through this
environment for about two hours yourself
as a player avatar wandering through
this more or less freely for six eight
hours
think of how unnerving and unsettling
that is I mean think of the things they
encounter think
the plants that are shaped like people
think of you know the bear
oh god that imagine encountering that in
a video game without knowing that it's
gonna be there and it's just it just
shows about our I mean heck the the film
practically has a final boss encounter
it'd probably be a QuickTime event the
way that it works but like I
I just came away thinking this should be
an atmospheric Syfy horror survival game
it would be amazing and I move it's not
often that I I take in a piece of
entertainment and think about boy it'd
be even better in this medium but it
happens sometimes and it happened with
this one I don't know if I'm alone in
that thought or not maybe I'm nuts don't
think too hard about that but coming
okay coming back to that bear it was
awesomely upsetting having this huge
bear missing most of its face and it
opens his mouth to do what should be a
roar and it's this dead woman screams of
help
God that was unsettling man that's an
unsettling enough concept but then how
it was executed visually man that was
unnerving and that's that's the other
thing about this movie the violence is
not pervasive but when it's there it is
brutal Wow yeah I mean this film was not
for the faint of heart so take that as a
warning before I get into spoilers that
yeah this thing earns its are rating and
it really does and like I said it's not
like it's not across the whole movie but
when it's there ya can't miss it overall
I just I really enjoy I enjoy head space
movies that require a little more work
to get your way through so I guess oh I
liked this movie I it lost me a little
bit in its third act but I did overall
like under the skin I
ex machina I like the fountain I enjoy
these kinds of movies that that sort of
take me to this really having to put my
thinking cap on and work it out as it's
going along you know in sci-fi concept
kind of things it's a really hard needle
to thread though because I'm also really
picky like you'd think this would mean I
like 2001 a Space Odyssey and I really
don't but that's kind of getting on a
tangent at this point but annihilation I
saw it I liked it a lot
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts were
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do you know the likes the
subscribes and buy t-shirt support me on
patreon why I don't know check out the
description down below for all the stuff
there is to do decide for yourself what
you feel I'm like but until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]